>> From the library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Sabrina Baron: -- to the last
meeting [inaudible] 2017-2018
academic year, we ran September,
October, November, February,
March, April in the
academic year.
So, this is going be our
last meeting for this year.
If any of you are not on our
email list and you'd like to be,
talk to myself or Eleanor
and we keep it [inaudible]
hopefully you don't have
to deliver it, if you're
interested in doing that.
We'll be working on a schedule
for next year starting on June.
So, if anybody is
interested in talking to us
or you have suggestions about
something, it might be good
for us to have and to talk to
us, we are always happy to--
we're always happy
to hear about that.
When we finish here, we'll
take our speaker Jason Farman
over to [inaudible]
for dinner and drinks
and everybody is
welcome to come along.
And so it's a good place to
continue the conversation
and ask questions and so forth.
So Eleanor is going to give
Jason a little bit more
in-depth introduction.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: Hi there.
It's our pleasure to
have Jason Farman.
He's an associate professor
at the University of Maryland
in the Department of
American Studies at--
in College Park, of course.
He's also the director
of design, culture,
and creativity program
and a faculty member
with the Human Computer
Interaction Lab,
very productive.
He is the author of the book
"Mobile Interface Theory",
which won the 2012 Book of
the Year from the Association
of Internet Researchers.
He's also the editor of the
book "Mobile Story" 2014,
and "Foundations of
Mobile Media Studies" 2016.
His most recent book has
undergone a retitling
and it's called "Delayed
Response: The Art of Waiting
from the Ancient World
to the Instant World."
Today he will be talking to us
about "Marks of Uncertainty:
Bodily Traces and Temporality
in Message Exchange".
>> Jason Farman:
Thank you very much.
So my talk today is going to be
drawn from one of the chapters
of my book, which is called
"Delayed Response" which will be
out this fall from Yale
University Press and it's funded
through the Alfred
P. Sloan Foundation.
So this should be out in
November and this is drawn
from one of the chapters.
The book is concerned with
the time lag between sending
and receiving messages.
I'm a digital media scholar
so I'm mostly looking
at mobile technologies and
I've been very interested
in tracing the history of
message exchange at time.
We've used our mobile
devices predominantly
for sending messages.
Since 2009 we've been
using our devices more
for sending messages and we
have a voice communication.
And the time between sending
and receiving messages is
really significant time
of interpretation and it
also shapes our experience
of duration as a whole.
So throughout the
book, I've gone back
through seven different eras
and objects of waiting looking
at how objects of waiting have
transformed the human experience
of time mostly looking at
how certain technologies
from message exchange
have shaped that in
between time of sending
a message.
And waiting in the book is
not simply in between time.
Waiting becomes an
interpretive moment.
Waiting becomes a core part
of the messages themselves.
It's something we interpret
through fear, anxiety, longing,
hope, or even boredom.
So I traced that throughout the
book how waiting becomes this
really key analytic for
understanding societies
and how they connect
across geographic distances.
It's also key for
knowledge production as well.
I want to show you some of
the objects study in a set
at the chapters of the book.
So I begin with text messages
and I work my way back doing
kind of a media archeology
of message exchange from our
contemporary moment looking
at text messages and designs of
waiting like buffering icons,
also how technologies in this
moment throughout history are
also key for the
development of knowledge
and knowledge production as we
share ideas across distances
as we send explorers
out into the unknown.
The chapter focuses on the space
program specifically looking
at the long delay it takes to
get data from the other end
of the solar system and how
that shapes what we know.
I look at the pneumatic tube
mailing system in United States
that began in the late 1890s all
the way to the 1950s and created
in the country this notion
of the instant messaging,
instant connection as you could
send messages to one another
within the hour all day long.
And I look specifically
at New York's pneumatic tube
mailing system for that.
I look at civil war letters and
the exchange of these letters,
how long they took and
shaped the rhythms of the day
and relationships the soldiers
and families back home had.
I look at medieval wax seals
which I'll talk about today.
And I go back all the way
to the very first messages
humans ever exchanged
with one another which were
aboriginal message sticks.
As humans migrated onto
the continent of Australia,
they used this sophisticated
communication system called
message sticks to
communicate with one another
about the landscape
and to share knowledge
as they would migrate
onto this space.
So in January of last
year, I was escorted
through several sets of alarmed
doors at the National Archives
in Kew in London, back to this
long row or archival boxes.
I was led there by Amanda
Bevan who's the head
of legal records there and
the lead researcher archivist
for the HCA Prize Papers.
So HCA is on all
of these boxes here
since with high court
of admiralty.
And she said-- she let me hear
and said back before post
offices, if you wanted
to send a letter to distant
relative or business contact,
you'd hand it to the nearest
ship's captain that was heading
in the right direction.
So often in pubs or coffee
houses you have mailbags
hanging, you would drop your
mail into the bag of the ship
that was heading in the general
direction of the recipient.
So the HCA letters
represented letters
that were captured
onboard enemy ships
that the royal maybe
had captured.
So these were from the mid
1600s to the early 1800s.
Any conflicts that England was
in as the royal navy
would capture ship,
one of the things plundered
on board would be a mail bag.
And they were saved as evidenced
in the high court of admiralty
because it was-- there was
major money to be made off
of the selling of the goods
onboard, but you have to prove
that it was an enemy ship.
And in order to prove that,
you could use the mail onboard
as evidence that it wasn't
simple a civilian ship,
it wasn't a ship that
was held by an ally
or it was an enemy ship.
And so these bags were
stored and they've been kept
in the archives since then.
And so, represented
in this long row
of archival boxes are thousands
of letters that never arrived.
And I asked Amanda Bevan,
how many letters are
in the prize papers which they
call the HCA Prize Papers?
And she said, I think it
would be an underestimate
to say 150,000.
So you're standing in this long
archival row and it just all
of the attempts that human
connection and communication
that are represented there, this
is very powerful moment for me.
So she pulls one of the
boxes down, we go over to one
of the tables that she and
her team are working at.
This is a picture of her working
with some of the letters.
And they're meticulously opening
these letters, one by one,
marking what's inside.
When I was there, this
was a Dutch letter
that was opened unsealed,
and inside of it
was a glass bracelet
that somebody was trying to
send to a distant relative.
And one of the archivists there,
Matt Greenhall, said to me,
"What you have here
is the equivalent
of an early modern post office
being invaded, essentially."
Many of these letters were
closed with a wax seal
to keep [inaudible] adhesive
to close them in here.
The letters still have
their seals intact.
The seals represented actually
the failure of communication.
They seals were never broken,
seals were never opened.
And I actually arrived to the
National Archives in London
to study medieval seals to try
to understand how a person marks
their identity onto a document
that leaves them and goes into
these networks of communication
to try to reach a distant other.
How do you mark your body?
How do you communicate
your identity
when the networks were
uncertain for a delivery?
That was my interest in there.
So, seals initially were
used as an adhesive to shut,
a letter that was meant to be
of confidence, a letter close.
So you would have a parchment
rolled up, string wrapped
around it, wax poured
over the string and marked
with the sender's matrix.
So it was destroyed
after it was opened
so very few of those
still exist.
But this practice actually
changed very early onto.
So Edward the Confessor
didn't want his seal
to be destroyed every
time somebody opened a
confidential letter.
He wanted the seal
to remain intact,
as evidence of his authorizing
power over the document.
So what he would do is
to create a pendant seal.
So on the parchment you
would have a couple of slits
where a thin piece of
parchment would be woven through
and then wax poured
where they met.
So regardless, the
seal remained intact,
as an authorizing object related
to the document for a person
to connect their identity
with that particular document.
Alternatively, some of the
seals that I worked with,
this was Henry I seal from 1115.
They would cut the bottom of the
parchment away and let it dangle
as sort of this pendant seal
that would hang from
the document.
So the seals here that
I studied and worked
with represent both the power
and the problem with distance.
There's tremendous power in the
ability for us to send messages
across vast geographic
distances.
It let us keep in touch
with distant others,
with business contacts
who were not nearby
but they also allow us to share
ideas beyond even our lifetime
or our specific geographies.
But the problem with
documents that are sent are
that we're not face to
face as we exchange this.
The body is removed from the
active communication here.
So, seals address this problem
by becoming a symbol of the hand
that stamped it, both
metaphorically and literally.
So, seals often incorporated the
imagery of the person actually
into the design, the body, the
person represented in the design
but making the seal impression
also links the human body
to its intentions
with the document.
So the act of sealing
represented the hand enacting
that symbol.
There's a saying from the
English King Alfred the Great
in the 9th century.
"Consider now, if your lord's
letter and his seal came to you,
whether you could say that
you could not recognize him
by this means."
So seals are instantly
recognizably even
by the illiterate within a
culture so many have argued
that there actually this
bridge object between literate
and illiterate culture
as documents begin circulating
largely within the everyday life
of common people, for the
illiterate, the seals serve
as this bridge to documents
that begin becoming a
part of everyday life.
So kings and queens had great
seals that were double-sided.
So on one side it's often
showing the sovereign
and some sort of military
power riding on a horse,
very powerful, a
knightly kind of figure.
And then on the other side
typically showed them sitting
on the throne in power,
holding a staff and orb.
And these are massive in size.
So this is King Henry VIII great
seal, which is-- that's my hand.
I was-- So all of
these, you know,
you must taken this entire
talk is within the context
of me being a digital media
scholar, sitting there looking
at this going, what in the
world, this is massive,
holding Queen Elizabeth
I great seal.
These are huge, the amount
of wax that they take as sort
of a mixture of beeswax
and resin to make these.
So this kind of seal, for
example, you have the obverse
and the reverse of
it are pressed
with a mechanism that's a little
bit similar to printing press
that puts both impressions-- the
impressions on both sides of it.
So the uncertainties
of geography
of message exchange require
verification of bodies
that aren't there and
some kind of symbol
that attaches the
body, links the body
with the documents
in some kind of way.
So the seals on the HCA Prize
Papers that I've first mentioned
and even these highlight
the uncertainty
of long distance communications
as documents begins being center
around the world in abundance.
So before post offices or
international infrastructures
in place for message delivery,
you had essentially a creative
combination of commerce,
transportation, and
ad-hoc messengers
that would get these
messages delivered.
So these create a social network
founded on uncertainty and also
and even expectations for reply.
In today's culture, we have
reciprocity and feedback design
into the very systems
that we used.
So a text message that you might
send will often say delivered
or read, attached to it,
which becomes instant feedback
that message delivery
has been successful.
And it creates this back
and forth, the reciprocity
that links us with the
people in our lives.
However, when the
infrastructures
and pathways ships mailbags
and trade routes made a
reply uncertain, I'm--
my driving question is how does
that change how we communicate?
How does that change
how we write?
How does that change our
relationship to documents
when a response might
never come, when our delays
for reciprocity might
be infinite?
The rise of a literate
public and the exchange
of documents really require the
available tools for writing,
literacy, methods of
exchange for these messages,
and also really require massive
cultural shifts, I think,
which are very familiar to this
group, you know I'm thinking
of Michael Clanchy saying,
the documents did not initially
inspired trust and memory
to written record where oral
testimony is well established
and it's easier to cross
examine somebody than it is
to trace the provenance
of a document.
But the power of documents
eventually overwhelmed these
by seas where documents
allow the letter writer to be
in multiple geographies also
across multiple times
beyond your own life,
yet things like plague
and war, seizure of mail
from these ships create
uncertainty for the networks.
So there are political and
cultural contacts which shaped
and influenced the speed
of message delivery,
how quickly a message
can deliver--
it really is impacted
by the context of it.
So these are never
neutral pathways.
There's instead the speed of
message exchange is influenced
by a sociopolitical landscape
or the events at the time.
And I think this
applies even to our own
as we're discussing net
neutrality as we're thinking
about the speed at which we
can exchange messages and data
across that network is
very much influenced
by our sociopolitical
moment and whether
or not we will regulated
message exchange.
And seals were one way that
letter writers were able
to exert influence
across distances
when they couldn't
be there face to face
when your body is
removed from message.
How do you, as someone
in the position of power,
exert that power when your body
is not there, with seals attempt
to communicate that
power in a visual way.
And so the very first centuries
of sealing in Britain--
and this is all in a British
context that I'm discussing--
seals were marks of power and
used by those with status alone.
So King Henry the II's chief
justice Richard de Lucy said,
"It was not formerly the
custom for every petty knight
to have a seal, which
benefits only kings
and important people."
So to have a matrix for a seal
meant that you are literate,
meant that you either were
in business or politics,
that you understood the
complexity of documents.
So just having a seal in
and of itself represented
a certain level
of status within the society.
It communicated the
importance of the person.
And thus, when you-- when
a document arrived to you
with a seal, which
is recognizable
and a response is expected
for that particular document,
a delay should not--
response should be delayed.
So urgency was a
key part of that.
So how seals exerted
their power--
the power of their
owners as they went
out was especially
important to women with seals,
who in a medieval context
for example didn't
necessarily carry power
but could exert a tremendous
influence over society.
And I went to look at
some of the seals of women
in the medieval period at
the Society of Antiquaries
of London, Burlington House.
And I was here with
a scholar of seals,
a sigillographer named
Elizabeth Danbury and she went
over to these long thin
drawers and pulled them out.
This is the archive of
seals that the Society
of Antiquaries has
been collecting
over the last 100 years or so.
And many of the women's
seals that we looked at draft
on the status of the
men in their lives
to communicate their
power, their own status,
their own right to
a certain level
of status within the society.
So there's iconography
drawn from husbands or sons
or fathers within them.
And this contrasted
interestingly Empress Matilda's
who was a 12th century
claimant to the throne who--
her grave site for example
says great by birth,
greater by marriage,
greatest in her offspring,
here lies daughter, wife
and mother of Henry.
Her seals, however, don't ever
use any of the men in her life
to communicate in
any kind of status.
She's holding an orb and a
staff and here is her great seal
that I study while
at the archives.
In order to study the seal,
it was an interesting process
that you have to study it
in their invigilation room.
So, there-- what's fascinating
about the national archives,
especially working with the
archives here in DC in contrast,
if you're over 60, you
got a reader's card
and you get the whole medieval
seals in your hand, you know?
They bring them out to
your reader's table.
Some of them, they were marked
as being able to only be seen
in the invigilation room
which are their best specimens
or perhaps the only
remaining specimen.
And this one is Empress
Matilda's great seal,
one of the only remaining ones.
So you know, they check
your bags and you get buzzed
into this locked
room, you sit down,
their surveillance camera is
all around you, and they bring
out the box with this object.
And for me, it was-- I
have studied the seal
and so did others through
books and digitized forms.
I took the seal out
and I flipped it over.
There are no-- There's no
photographs or digitization
of the reverse of these seals,
unless there's some kind
of impression on it.
And there were all these
fingerprints on the back,
which were made at the time of
impression when the wax is hot.
And there-- it was fascinating
to trace how the body
interacting with these seals.
And sometimes intentional ways
and sometimes unintentional
ways,
like the fingerprints
on the back.
There's sigillographers now
doing some really interesting
forensic studies on
the fingerprints.
We were actually the people
that are sealing these things
of the fingerprints
common across.
So for me, the-- I began
looking for this in these ways,
you know, what can't I get
through digitize means,
what's missing from a lot of
the documentation of these seals
and it's the marks of
the body on these seals
that I found fascinating.
It traces it back to--
in one sense, William
the Conqueror said
that he would seal the document
with his fang tooth, you know?
He would mark it-- instead
of using a matrix, I bite it,
you know, I bite it
and that's my mark.
So the marks of the body, you
know, go back to very early
on when it was really important
for us to imagine the seals
as how connecting to the
physical body of the person.
And many of the seals
that I was working
with have these knuckle marks
of deep fingerprints in the back
of the seal as a
mark of the body.
And these to me capture-- what
interest me about the seals is
that in what they're
meant to symbolize.
They symbolize the presence
at the document of the body
of the person sending
the message.
So when uncertainty of
message exchange is present,
what you have often is a removal
of non-verbal cues, eye contact,
of gesture, sort of physicality.
So how do you mark your body
when the body is removed
from that interaction?
So seals communicate authority,
physical embodied
authority going out--
my body is not with you so I
send this mark in its stead.
So the seal is a mechanical
reproduction, though,
which as someone who studies
media is an interesting thing
where mechanical reproduction
creates what Walter [inaudible]
has talked about as sort of
this troubled relationship
over the aura of the object
or that the significance
of an object that gives it
its power and its rarity.
And this was understood within
this context throughout sealing
and sealing practices in
Britain, there was an--
a troubled relationship between
this idea of reproducibility
and someone's identity.
Especially as the bureaucracy
moved along, kings and queens
at some points rarely
impress their own seals,
they didn't use their own hand
to do it, they had people to do
that for them and the
seal matrix gets further
and further away from the
body of the sovereign.
And then you have
the introduction
of signet ring seals, which are
worn by the person at all times.
It's a way of connecting
that to the body.
It doesn't leave the body.
It's not used by other people.
So, there's a-- within
this context,
also at early Christian context,
around the active impression
that I find fascinating where
within the Christian ideology,
we are made in the image of God,
and the active impression
is similarly a godlike act
of creation of impressing
yourself onto the document.
So you're connecting,
you're making in the image
of especially quite literally
sometimes where your body is
on that matrix, you are
making your identity impressed
into the wax the same way
we are made in the image of.
Miriam Bedos-Rezak, who is a
scholar of seals at NYU told me
that documents-- there's
always been a relationship
between identity
and reproducibility.
For us, our signatures
are recognizable
because we do them
over and over again.
They're not identical
but they are recognizable
in the reproducibility.
And for documents, they are seen
as authentic because in a sense
because of this reproducibility.
For Bedos-Rezak, she says
reproducibility is the condition
of authenticity.
So as we send out
word to distant others
and these delivery routes
move from precarious
to less precarious, there are
wait times for the delivery
of messages that are slow
either because of interception
like the HCA Price Papers or
the document will come to you
and have been-- it's
either accepted completely
or it arrives to you
with a broken seal
that is a visual mark
that a letter close
has been intercepted
and can no longer be
trusted as private
or changed along those lines.
So, concerns about privacy
and how that term changes
across history and within
its particular moments are
characteristics of
these uncertain networks
of message exchange.
So there's a middle ground that
deliver it out and fascinated
in throughout the book.
And part of what this-- happens
in this middle ground is
what I call surveillance
from the middle, where it's
intercepted in some ways
and either the message is
lost or the message comes
with visual cues that somehow
it has been intercepted
during transit.
So I came across a really
interesting example of this
as I was working in wartime
correspondents out at
in Orange County,
California, there's a Center
for American War Letters.
And one of the letters I-- sets
of letters that I was working
with was from a cadet from World
War I who is stationed in France
and he would-- his
name is Walter Boadway
and he would write a ton
of letters back to his wife
in Pasadena, California.
And the letter started arriving
with these strange holes in them
and she would write back to him
that your letters are being cut
apart, sometimes huge sections
of them just cut away.
So these weren't military
sensors that were blocking
out sensitive words, they
were taking razors or scissors
and cutting out complete
sections of his letters back
to his wife, taking out any
sort of classified information.
And Walter Boadway didn't quite
know what classified meant
because it was changing
from moment to moment.
So at one point, he
couldn't talk about what kind
of plane he flew, so
that was taken out,
cut out of the letters.
At other points, he
was no longer allowed
to date-mark his letters.
So instead of November 11, 1917,
he just had to write Sunday.
So he used both sides
of the letters here
as he would communicate
with his wife back home.
And then as these
words or sentences
or paragraphs were
literally erased or taken
out from the material, pieces
of paper, that practice
of interception was revealed.
So for Boadway he knew a sensor
was going to read his letters.
You just know that
that's the pathway.
However for Betty, his wife,
these physical transformations
to the paper evidence of the
flow communication, from Walter,
to sensor, to her in
Pasadena, California.
So the system of
interception is revealed
and perhaps ways analogous
to a seal being broken
on the letter close.
So when people become
aware of the consequences
of these interceptions,
they engage in tactics
to avoid these consequences.
So Boadway at first just
tries changing what he writes.
I'm going to-- I will try to
avoid classified discussions.
I'll keep it everyday.
But it still, he ended up having
his letters cut to pieces.
So eventually he's like, I
have to write on one side
of the sheet of paper because
otherwise, it's going to get cut
out and on the reverse
it's going to--
she won't be able to read what's
on the other side of the paper.
So you absorbed the cost of
sending more sheets of paper
because he wasn't quite sure how
to avoid surveillance
from the middle.
And he knew about this
through reciprocity,
through his wife writing
back to him, and say,
your letter came in
shreds, you know?
I could not even read
the last thing you wrote,
this entire section was cut out.
So reciprocity is one of
those ways, historically,
we've known that
our letter arrived.
We get word back.
We get some kind of confirmation
that it was delivered
successfully.
And in Civil War letters-- I
have a chapter that focuses
on Civil War letters
exclusively.
And like many times, people--
you know, the genre dictated
that you began your letter
with some kind of time,
narrative time stamp
like I received your letter
September 22nd yesterday.
Or like this letter which
is a little hard to read
but he writes, "The
last letter you wrote
to me did not reach here
until yesterday owing
to being missent."
So time stamping it, you are
probably expecting a response
to that letter, it didn't
arrive until yesterday
and he's got a date
mark on his letter.
The soldier that I focused
on most is Joseph
Choreal [assumed spelling]
who was a part of the 24th
Michigan who left DeWitt,
Michigan to come out here
to the DC area to fight
with the Army of the Potomac.
And he writes to his wife
in this letter, you know,
I've been gone for over a month
and I still haven't had any word
from home, there's
been no letters.
I don't know if you're
getting my letters.
Please just write often
so that hopefully some
of them will arrive.
Some of them will get through.
Because again, that
network of message exchange
in this era especially,
is so fascinating
because you're having those
moments starting in 1847
with the introduction of
postage stamps and sort
of standardized postage systems,
you have people writing in mass.
So here is the first
American conflict
where people are writing
at an unprecedented level
and the networks for message
delivery are precarious,
unknown, they get letters get
stolen all the time especially
trying to find money
within those letters.
So he says, please just
write often, hopefully some
of them will get through.
And within the context of the
book and my focus on time,
it's been interesting to trace
how some people can actually
withhold their response
as a power maneuver.
And this is true
throughout history.
We still do this today where
you can make somebody wait
for a response a little bit
longer as a way of, you know,
exerting your own power
within that relationship
and that power dynamic.
And an interesting example
came in July 13th of 1533
when a letter arrived to
Pope Clement VII asking him
to grant dispensation to
annul Henry VIII marriage
to Catherine of Aragon.
So on that document, there are
81 pendant seals attached to it
of the lords and archbishops
who authorized the document.
And these were-- these seals
were essentially a visual
communication of their
authority to the pope to say
if you don't do this, we
will find means elsewhere.
So, it was sent to
the pope, Henry waited
for a response and
the pope delayed.
The pope decided to wait.
He is going to wait it out.
He communicated his
power in that situation
to Henry VIII by waiting.
He was using it as a tactic
to emphasize his own power,
however that strategy
infuriated Henry VIII
who felt he was too
powerful to wait any longer
and then he had an active
parliament advertised
to Roman Catholic Church and
install him as the supreme head
of the Church of England.
Tactics of delay
cause uncertainty
in our own era as well.
So you can imagine similar sort
of power maneuvers and tactics
that carry out across
history and different moments,
how people use delays
and wait time
to exert power or influence.
And in the digital age,
this is true as well.
Again, going back to those
text messages that are marked
as read, they are
verified to the sender
and it provides a correspondent
with immediate feedback,
your message has been delivered.
And once it has been
read, like here,
the feedback that's
given then is
that there should
be a quick response.
And if there isn't a quick
response, people are left
to interpret that silence
and we do in many ways,
it shapes our interpersonal
interactions with another
and becomes an interpretative
moment of trying
to understand the relationship
and the power dynamics
within that relationship.
In Japan, most of the
population within the country,
95% of them use a
messaging app called Line.
And this is a Line
screenshot right there.
And within Line, every message
that is sent comes
with a re-received.
You can't turn it off.
So everybody who's back
and forth with each other
on their phones, when the
message pops up and is read
by the person, it marks it read.
You can't turn it off.
You can't.
Within the United States, a
lot of us use iMessage which is
over here, you know, you
have delivered and read.
But a lot of people
turn this off.
So you don't want
people to necessarily see
when you read the message.
In Japan, there's no
option, everybody knows
when their messages
has been read.
So I met with the executives
and designers at Line in Tokyo
in their Shinjuku offices
to talk about this.
And one of the key aims for
them was that this app was built
in the aftermath of the
Tohoku 9.1 earthquake.
When people are trying
to send messages
to each other connect
right after the earthquake,
message infrastructures
were down and slow
and people weren't sure if their
messages were getting through.
So they said we're
going to build an app
that lets people know as soon
as the message has been read.
And that is enough, you know,
just to have your message marked
read, I know you're there,
I know you got it, you
may not be able to respond
but that feedback is
enough for me to know
that the message has been
successfully delivered.
It's read, it's a
different kind of feedback
and reciprocity there.
And what's emerged
out of that, however,
is really interesting two terms
in Japanese kidoku-through
and miduko-through.
So ki means already, and doku
means read and then they borrow
from the English word through.
So kidoku-through is a message
that is already been
read through.
Midoku-through, mi means not yet
so midoku-through is a message
that has not been
marked as read.
And with the Japanese college
students that I talked to,
this shapes their experience
of time in extraordinary ways.
So if a message is marked
kidoku-through, you've read it
and you don't respond to
me in a timely manner,
that is either seen as a
sign of disrespect or again,
going to back to
that power maneuver,
I'm withholding a
response to reiterate
that my time is more
valuable than yours
and you can wait for it.
So, waiting is-- for
messages, is often a result
to these geographic distances
when people are far apart
from each other and on-- the
only motive communication
that they have require
significant wait times
or within that, wait times due
to this distance will often
efface the bodies of the people
who are communicating
unless there's some kind
of visual marker
that attach that.
So seals, reinsert the
body into those exchanges.
They mark and authenticate
documents
when people can't
be there together.
And in the digital age, we
require similar authentication
in an era where much of our
exchanges are based on messages.
Again, we use our mobile
devices more for messages
and voice communication.
We're using email, we
exchange documents.
So the digital ages, is one
where we privilege messages
and those messages continue to
require proof of authenticity.
So we have passwords, we
have two-step authentication,
we memorize pass codes to unlock
our mobile devices or even now
with facial recognition
where you look at it
and your body actually
unlocks the phone,
or with your thumbprint, my
thumbprint unlocks my phone,
so your body as a means of
authenticating who you are
to allow you to send
the message.
And seals haven't disappeared
altogether within society.
In fact they're widely used
still today around the world.
In United States, we-- each
state has its own seal,
we use them to authenticate
legal documents, official pieces
of legislation, cultural
institutions,
universities have seals,
there's an interesting story,
Victor Mair who's a professor of
Chinese Language and Literature
at University of Pennsylvania
was working with a director
of an archeological institute
in China and they were going
to transfer some artifacts
to him so he could use them
in his studies, he could
carbon-date them, but in order
to carbon-date them, he had to
have a document that authorize
and told people these artifacts
now belong to Victor Mair.
So the director
of the archeological institute
said we've just undergone a
renaming and a reorganization
and we're still waiting
on our seal so I can't send you
document until our seal comes in
and the seal kept getting
delayed and delayed
and then eventually,
Professor Mair said,
I can't wait any longer, can you
please just send authorization
with your signature?
And the director
laughed and said
that such a document
would be worthless.
And he finally acquiesce
and sent the document
with his signature and was
absolutely surprised and stunned
to see that that was accepted
and that was actually just
as valuable as having a seal
on that particular document.
And seals are very common in
Asian countries and are used
by most citizens
to sign their names
on government documents as well.
So every person I spoke within
Japan carries their own seal
with them, called hanko or
more formal version, inkan.
So the seal is carried on
you at all times and it's--
you sign every document with
it using ink instead of wax.
You'll have five different hanko
within your lifetime,
for example.
And if you're in
particular lines of business,
you might have to carry
three on you at a given time,
so the practice started in the
country in the 1870s with rise
in and bureaucracy and
the need for people
to authenticate things.
And then what should now
be a familiar trajectory,
people in power had
them initially
and now they can be bought
and in the neighborhood shop
as seen in this picture here.
So there is a long lineage of
authentication that's been born
out of the way times and
geographies of communication.
So those wait times in
geographies [inaudible].
We continue to create
modes of linking our bodies
to our messages, finding
ways to connect our bodies
across these distances as we
send messages across them.
So wait times makes as
communicate differently,
how they shape the
way we communicate,
they shape the way we
interpret messages and we seek
to create messages adapted
to these particular networks
and the times of those networks
and the expectations
of response.
And the possibility
of interception
at a message might not arrive.
So waiting for me is this really
interesting and important lens
to understand different
societies
and their message technologies.
So how they connected, how they
define things like intimacy
and connectivity, the
local, their geographies,
but also ultimately how waiting
and has been a silent force
that shapes these societies
at each ear as a technology
through sharing messages
shape the human experience
at the time.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> We have time for
questions and discussion.
>> Yes?
>> Well, my area of expertise
is slightly different area
but I just want
to add [inaudible] the
question I've written my book is
Anthony [inaudible].
And he was a postman
for 37 years.
>> Jason Farman: Nice.
>> And in his novel
[inaudible] he uses letters.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> And he has particular
epistolary situations
and he makes great--
and unlike other people
who have [inaudible], he tells
you how the letter got there.
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
>> And what could happen is
it's very-- yes, the wait time,
I'll just give one example
[inaudible] Frank goes to London
and Mary doesn't know
if he still loves her.
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
>> He writes her a letter but
the letter doesn't get to her
and is left in the post office
because she doesn't
have the power
to have a [inaudible]
to pick it up.
Meanwhile she can write
a letter and if it goes
to the other house, somebody
in the house will take
that letter to London.
Meanwhile she suffers terribly
and she goes and
she's, you know--
>> Jason Farman: Exactly.
>> -- it is all bout power who
can hold the letter [inaudible].
The pillar box is
a great [inaudible]
because then you could sneak out
the house and you could put--
and nobody-- once the letter is
in the pillar, you
can't take it.
So [inaudible] uses this over
and over again just waiting,
how the letter got
there, when it arrived,
what point in time it arrived.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> I was very struck by
the [inaudible] seals
that you have to stamp it.
And of course, this
time the NP has a seal,
to [inaudible] letter,
so the letter can go.
But by [inaudible] time,
become more egalitarian.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
That's what drew me to this.
And you see this over and
over again in literature,
in stories where, you know,
certain narrative plots play
out because of delays
or lost letters,
lost messages that get sent.
And for my own work, within
my field of mobile technology,
we predominantly focused on
the words we have exchanged,
the content, the
images, the videos,
and a few people have talked
about the infrastructures
that make that possible and
that temporality of that,
that's a part of that.
So I think to understand
the documents,
it's been interesting working
with the sigillographers
in this sense because there's
been sort of this divide
between people who study
the document and people
who study the seals and they--
only within, I guess you know,
the past several years that they
brought them together to think
of them as this whole, and
especially to think of them
within the larger
networks, infrastructures
that allow the delivery of
these things as being central
to understanding the
message in and of itself.
And I think that that's
a really great example.
And how generals play out
and how different
people are expected
to wait differently is also
very fascinating like, you know,
the-- and I think this endures
as well who's expecting to wait
for a message and how that plays
out certain gender stereotypes
of waiting, who's allowed to
not wait, yeah, it's all, to me,
this really fascinating
lens on different societies
that I think opens up some of
the questions that definitely
in the field of media studies
have been asked enough.
>> Just [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> What is that that Facebook
is undergoing such scrutiny?
But the original Facebook--
because years ago my husband was
on Facebook early on
when it first came on,
is his great innovation was
to have somebody's face.
At the early run, you didn't
put cat, you put your face.
And the other one is that a new
group opened up to replace Yahoo
which doesn't work
very well [inaudible].
And I moved three groups
around that and the big thing
about that is instant
movement because no way
that everything comes quickly
and there's three different
lists where you can go and say,
oh, the message didn't
come and you can get help
to make sure it came, all about
delivery, speed [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's been really interesting
to trace the notion
of the instantaneous
across these eras,
especially from the nomadic
era where people were enchanted
with the speed of the technology
and it felt like you were living
in the modern moment,
you know, where--
because when the pneumatic
tube system first began,
you had mail delivery
through wagons and horses
in New York, for example.
So all of a sudden,
you've got this, you know,
this hums of these canisters
flying under the city streets
of 30 miles an hour,
delivering mail, you know,
to you within an hour, and
it could go all day long
where you can just
send messages,
and all of a sudden we're living
in this modern moment and sort
of tracing the promise of ever
accelerating means of connecting
with each other back
through history as we try
to really reduce the speed
so we can connect in faster
and faster ways imagining
that that might bridge the gap
of geography in a
sense, you know?
In that book, I ultimately
argue I'll always be waiting,
you know, we'll never
close that gap.
And actually the promise of the
instant is more of an allure
to connect us with
particular kinds of and future
and to truly understand
why we'll always actually
send messages.
We'll always send messages
that can be responded
to whenever people get a chance,
rather than these synchronous
moments of communication.
So waiting is often this-- it's
simultaneously, it's something
that needs to be
eliminated from society
because we think it's holding
us back from the things we want
or that relationships we want.
It's also this opportunity
for companies to kind
of pitch something that's going
to be the next technology that's
going to bridge us instantly.
It's more on mythology
than anything.
I think we'll be waiting
forever so we don't have
to imagine what that means.
>> Yeah, it's really
interesting.
Thank you.
So we have a bunch of
different questions for the--
I just wanted to kind of
share like looking at kind
of from an archival
perspective is very interested
in how you kind of bring into
a sense of body and embodiment
and how these messages are
constructed particularly
and then [inaudible] messages
you can see everything
because a lot of the attention
there is on diplomatic
and not necessarily
these sort of extra--
well, not extra but
integral parts [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman: Yes, exactly.
Yeah.
>> So it's-- I was really
fascinated on how you're kind
of bringing in that
sense of identity.
>> Jason Farman: Great.
>> And I'm kind of interested
if you can say something more
about personalization to sort
of what we're seeing
now with messages.
But there's also this comment
that I just wanted to share
and thinking about like, what
we are sort of seeing now
with the ambiguity of messaging,
I think, versus [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman:
Yeah, right, right.
>> Using email-- I mean
these sorts of technologies,
the internet technologies
are not necessarily designed
with [inaudible] line, they're
designed to ensure sending.
>> Jason Farman: Right.
>> And so, I had this experience
using email where you get people
that want [inaudible]
receipts which is something
that some system
support now and I feel
like it's a kind of aggressive.
>> Jason Farman:
Absolutely, yeah, yeah.
>> It's [inaudible] that you're
ignore the message [inaudible].
So I was interested to
know if you kind of explore
that [inaudible] as well.
But I'm kind of more
curious about personalization
of these little things.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah,
yeah, definitely.
I guess to begin
with, the email thing.
Yeah, when I have
described lines,
requirement of a read
receipt to college students
in the United States, I freak
out, like, oh, that is invasive,
you know, because it does
then set a certain burden
of expectation on relationships.
So as we interface
with technologies,
the speed of communication
is built to have experience.
So as you, you know,
look across eras,
we set our expectations based
on our experience with this.
So we send the message,
the time it takes
to come back sets a standard
and then we begin
shaping our temporalities
around that rhythm.
So this is through
read receipts as well.
So based on a particular
relationship,
that read receipt would have
certain expectations, you know,
sending a text to your mother
versus your significant other,
you have different sort
of temporal expectations.
I remember when I was in
college as an undergrad
and got my first email address.
The emails came as you
would send something,
it kind of had a little piece of
code that it was attached to it
that when the message is
open, I got responses to that.
And this was I think
maybe a part
of my colleges email
system at the time.
But for me as a first
time sort of email user,
this sets standards for
expectations on replies.
And I think that people
want to be able to shape
that a little bit to their
context and to their moment,
which is why I think the
read receipts feel a little
aggressive, because instant--
it sets an expectation instantly
without you getting involved.
The people at line said
that what's going on now is
that when you get a notification
on your phone from line,
what they'll will do
they'll press and hold it,
so it pops up on the screen
and they can kind of preview it
without opening and
breaking the seal on that.
So they're coming up with
tactics to kind of shape.
>> Yeah. I was wondering.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
And so the second part of that,
personalization, the seals,
was again, I think a core
part of my interest in that.
And then I came to
this out of looking
at the aboriginal message
sticks which as a mode
of authentication would
sometimes have the tribal
leader's hair attached
to the document--
actually a stick not a document.
So as a way of verifying
and personalizing that thing
that this came from this
particular person and the seals
that I looked at in
terms of the relationship
between the identity and
the iconography on there,
I think was essential to
really the power of the seal.
So they require a presentation,
but then you get into the,
you know, 17th century and
you can buy a seal, you know,
at the corner shop and
you begin having seals
that aren't necessarily
attached to your identity
and they're not personalized
in any particular kind
of way unless you're
somebody with means
or very particular
kinds of power.
So as it disseminates
and gets broader,
it becomes less personal and it
becomes more utilitarian rather
than linked with a
specific person's identity.
So you have a sailor and
it's a ship, know, ship seal.
>> And these ones-- like
the one you have up there--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> -- I think those
were the seals
that you mentioned
[inaudible] using, I think?
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
Yeah.
>> So are those the only sort
of oval-shaped ones that--
>> Jason Farman: No.
Yeah. You know, you
would have a lot
of religious officials
having the shape.
This is a privy seal.
So yeah, the shape-- yeah,
there-- it just depends.
There were certain standards,
so you had great seals taking
on particular shapes,
sometimes privy seals, but--
so there were certain
expectations
but no, beyond that--
>> In all different sizes.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
Yes, all different sizes.
>> Statement is smaller than
the privy so it's bigger
than the [inaudible] seal.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
Yes.
>> It's bigger.
>> Well, I just think it's
really interesting thinking
about this in terms
of like [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
>> It's very clear like when
it's a [inaudible] if you go
over to the national archives
and you see there's exhibitions
of trees, right, like they're
sort of ceremonial, symbolic,
and authenticating devices,
that sort of personal element
isn't something that's usually
like it's part of
the archival record?
>> Jason Farman: Yes, right.
>> But it's interesting
[inaudible].
>> Jason Farman: Yeah, exactly.
Right, yeah, indeed.
And I'm looking at a very
particular kind of message too,
where the dominant
documents that I looked
at are they're archives,
you know?
There's not a response
that's meant to take place.
So I'm more interested in the
kinds of documents and messages
that expect exchange and
as a part of that exchange
and then press the
body into that.
So I think the body
is, is it important
for those documents becomes
this authenticating power
that is very personalized,
but in terms of interpersonal,
but there is no interpersonal
there.
It's not about message
exchanges.
It's about the archive
and the sense.
>> It's your turn?
>> No, go ahead.
>> I'm interested in the
idea of counterfeiting seals.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> I was watching the
film about Elizabeth I
and her master spy
intercepting Mary,
Queen of Scots' letters
and [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman: Depending
on if it was private or not.
So most documents
that would exchange,
there's no assumption
of privacy.
So the uncertain
network and part is
that you've sacrificed privacy
to let this document
be out into the world.
So unless it's a letter
close, that assumes some kind
of privacy, the seals
wouldn't have been broken
because it would have just
hung impended form from that.
Seals were duplicated.
There were forgeries
quite a bit, again,
with this reproducibility that's
the factor that's at play here,
impart to help offset that,
anytime a sovereign was
then removed from power
for some reason or died, their
matrix would be destroyed.
And so with that-- you know,
trying to eliminate the
possibility of somebody using
that and sort of forging
documents from then on.
So yeah, forgery I think is
at the [inaudible] the
reproducible technology
like a seal matrix and then,
you know, trying to find ways
to deal with that, and much
the same way that we're--
I think that we've always
dealt with these documents,
how do you authenticate them
and make sure that they're--
they aren't forgeries.
Yeah, it's fascinating tracing
how people have dealt with seals
that get lost or stolen and the
cost it's paid and all of these.
It's a very interesting
topic to study.
>> Oh, James II [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman: Right.
>> And you could-- you
know, they're waxed, right?
They're malleable.
So there are stories about
people heating up knives
and things, and you can
take it off that way
and then you can
heat up the back side
of it and put it back on.
>> Jason Farman: Right, right.
>> Because it's malleable.
But where-- This
is actually famous
by the way [inaudible]
things that sit
into my brain really,
really [inaudible].
So, reproducibility, right?
So when the printing press
comes along, matrix [inaudible],
printing press is
a whore, right?
It's promiscuous.
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
That's right
>> It's not reproducible,
it's promiscuous.
And then I work on manuscript
news in the early 17th century
in England and if it's
printed, it's suspect.
>> Jason Farman: Right, yes.
>> Because there
is so much of it.
It's impersonal.
It's the letter that's
written with your own hand
that that's the most reliable
and the most verifiable.
>> Jason Farman:
Right, right, right.
Yeah, indeed.
Yeah and that's the context.
I think that that is the
context of understanding seals
and their problematic nature.
And as someone coming to
this field as an outsider--
so my methods for this kind of
project are more like journalism
than they are sort
of deep archive work.
I went to a lot of seal
scholars and I said,
teach me about this
thing, I'm interested.
I want to make-- draw
all the connections.
So as someone-- As an outsider
coming into this field, I was,
you know, interested in
why is the seal valued
over this signature, when
these particular eras.
There are times when they
are both used but why
at this moment is
this more authentic
than my cultural understanding
of a signature which has
to be done by your
hand, you know,
can be forged the same
way a seal can be forged
but this is removed
from the body, you know?
You have these people doing
it on your behalf, you know?
That to me is a very strange
juxtaposition of trying
to understand, authenticating
at an attachment
to a person's identity with
the document and the role
of the written hand, you
know, as being there.
So I think they are suspect.
I think that they are--
they exist within
attention around authority
and reproducibility, but
I think from me anyway,
that piece that has settled that
is this notion of imprinting,
you know, of the act
of imprinting taking
on a certain sort of
Christian ideology onto the act
of authorizing a document which
had value above the written hand
in a sense, you know, the act
of making an impression link
to this longer notion
of creating something,
of bringing something
into being in a sense
which had more symbolic weight
than simply signing,
if that make sense.
>> It's what we call the
printing press for that matter.
But there would have been a time
when people who were very elite
and the kind of people
who are privileged
and have seals couldn't
sign their names, right?
So in that case, it's
definitely authenticated
because there'll
be a secretaries,
scribers writing for them.
And it's a corollary
to the people
who then are not
writing [inaudible] who,
you know, they make their mark.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah, exactly.
>> And a lot of those are
drawn and it just ends
and so on and so forth.
So there's a lot of
interesting connectivity.
>> Jason Farman: Absolutely.
Yeah, that's right.
>> And the other one I want
to ask about is anxiety.
You know, you're talking about
this moment of interpretation
and [inaudible] that
says you're waiting
to get the message creates
this anxiety in a society
and that, you know,
it's the bad side of anxiety,
it's not the anticipation
good side of anxiety.
What do you think about that?
>> Jason Farman: I
think it's contextual.
I think it's dependent
on the context.
So yeah, waiting means
so many different things
which is why it's so
rich to study I think
because waiting can
be something.
One of the questions I ask
to get the answer for this is
who benefits from me waiting?
That's a question I begin with.
So in one part, I can
benefit from me waiting,
where I am investing my time
and it becomes something
that pays back to me in
delayed response for--
or, you know, delayed
gratification.
We often imagine waiting
as developing the virtue
of patience and we've-- you
know, we honor those kids
who waited for the researcher
to come back in the room
with a second marshmallow.
You know, they don't eat the
first marshmallow, they waited
and the researcher
brought them two.
And those are the people very
successful in life, right?
So waiting can benefit us.
But then on the other hand,
it sometimes benefits
certain structures
that keep people
at disadvantages.
And the thing that's emerged out
of this work is that as I look
at how people wait across
history and in our own moments,
it's obvious that time
is not distributedly--
distributed evenly and certain
people have to use their time
in different ways because
they're not [inaudible] the same
kind of time than others are.
So how we interpret that way,
time is very much dependent
on how time is distributed to
us within a particular moment.
Do I have the ability to
wait and instead of anxiety,
I have hope and promise
and I'm--
and I use this wait time
to imagine a future
that is not yet.
And that to me, I argue, in my--
in the chapter on buffering
icons, we're actually half
in love with these like symbols
of waiting because what's
on the other side
of those symbols
of waiting is this
other future, you know?
And it could be anything
and we hope--
we have a lot of hope that when
I'm refreshing my social media
feed that what comes on the
other side of that is going
to be the thing I'm
looking for, you know,
the thing that I desire.
So if you look at people-- Apple
taps into the cultural ideas
around waiting in
really interesting ways.
The iPhone will be launched this
day and we wait and we wait.
And then the day comes and we
wait in line and it connects us
to this product and it's
this tool that is used
to create attachment
rather than anxiety and fear
and it builds kind of a longing
and a relationship to something.
So it depends on who you are,
how time is distributed to you,
and within that particular
context how waiting gets
interpreted I think.
>> [Inaudible] I was going to--
actually I have two questions,
one is kind of segue
on your comments
from the last question
you asked.
I was going to ask the title--
the change of title because
you had waiting for word
and you just talked so much
about waiting there
and their response.
And you also talked about the
importance of conceptualization,
waiting for work [inaudible]
at delayed response ships.
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
>> And I just wanted to say
the kind of change of title.
>> Jason Farman: You have to
talk to the press about that.
That's actually a press change.
>> Is it a press change?
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
Part of it-- the contemporary
I think misunderstanding
of that phrase of waiting for
word and how it's less used.
People had thought I was going
to write about Microsoft Word
or they thought it
was a religious book
about waiting for
the word of God.
>> OK.
>> Jason Farman: So
there was confusion,
which I didn't quite understand
and I quite like
the first title.
So this is a particular
kind of book for the press.
So this is a trade addition.
So yeah, so this is meant
for a broad audience
and they want a book that
both communicates time
and messages, and
so that's, yes.
>> Yeah. That's--
>> Jason Farman: But
I agree, I agree.
>> Yeah. It was no [inaudible]
thinking actually, you know,
if you think of [inaudible]
change the title
and all the problems that came
in from [inaudible] change,
which is very different
from printing press
and the price tags were changed.
So anyway, I've been
[inaudible].
>> Oh, thank you.
Thanks. Do you [inaudible]
project like telegraphs
and things like that
sitting in between?
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
Yeah. So I'm not to the
telegraph and pneumatic tube.
I decided not to write
about the telegraph
because I was looking mostly at
messages exchange on an intimate
in every day level while
the telegraph was, you know,
predominantly used by--
for business uses
and things like that.
So you didn't have sort of the
massive use of the telegraph
to exchange intimate
messages on the scale
of the pneumatic tubes.
I thought the pneumatic tubes
serve as a better example.
But moving from the telegraphic
era to the pneumatic era,
I think there's this
seamless cultural imaginary
around the instant that
emerges at this period of time
and I just felt that the
pneumatic tubes were the better
example of what I
wanted to talk about.
>> Talking about
some [inaudible]?
>> Jason Farman: Yes.
Yeah, yeah indeed.
>> Just what you were
saying about waiting,
like who has the
authority of power
to make someone wait [inaudible]
about like community
temporality--
state temporalities and who's--
who has the authority
to define time.
>> Jason Farman: Right, yes.
>> And the state [inaudible]
thinking about things
like court dates, like for
permits and things like that
versus community and
individual temporalities
and what your time
availabilities
and who [inaudible]?
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> So that's an interesting
connection.
And also thinking about the
seals that we see as the sort
of like embodiment of
authority putting in line
of Twitter and we verify each--
>> Jason Farman: The seal, yes.
>> And the thing too,
the authorizing mark
that that serves for those
individuals on a platform
that quite by the way is also
the home for the [inaudible],
like thinking about what is
their obligation for a company
like that when negotiating
authority in unanimity that both
of which are [inaudible].
>> Jason Farman:
Yes, right, right.
>> [Inaudible] what are their
obligations [inaudible].
>> That's great, great comments.
I really appreciate that.
To the first point, this
dynamic about who gets
to define temporarily emerge
when I was in Australia working
with the Wurundjeri
tribe talking to them
about their histories
of the message sticks.
And when colonizers first came
into both Sydney and Melbourne,
they imagine that they had
come across prehistoric people
that were without time,
that they didn't experience
that because you needed
technology to understand time.
You needed some sort of
time telling technology,
and the message sticks were
that, because they were linked
to the geography of the space
that took a certain amount
of time to journey between
tribes and then to gather people
and often these sticks were used
for gatherings called
corroborees
where tribes would
come together.
So they-- you know, here
you have this culture
that was sending long distance
messages, tens of thousands
of years before European
settlers were but they came in
and said these people
don't have any time.
And that has persisted
to this day,
that notion that aboriginal
people are timeless
and without time.
You know, I would talk to some
of the university professors
there and I say, yeah, I have--
I'm going over to
Coranderrk to meet
with some Wurundjeri elders.
And they said, well, you
know, don't get there early,
they're probably going
to be late, you know?
So these cultural notions
about lateness and sort
of how certain cultures are
temporarily challenged as a way
to create, you know,
this race's notions
about different societies
definitely emerged
in that example.
And I think, yeah,
you definitely see
that throughout societies
today as well.
And in terms of the relationship
between the unanimity
and the authorization,
I think that that's--
that is a fascinating ship.
I think that would be
interesting to the study
as a whole, you know,
specially the move
from early online
networks to notions
of authenticating certain
identities online today.
I think we have more
assumption around authenticity
than unanimity today that--
you know, when you go on to
a political post like looking
at the parkland students,
this is really interesting,
I've been doing this lately.
Look at parkland students post.
Go into the comments
especially the negative ones.
Most of those people have 5
to 11 followers and, you know,
you wonder who-- we assume
that somebody's got a picture
and a Twitter identity
that that is--
you know, this real life
person responding to this.
But I think the emergence of
bots and these other platforms
for replicating things bring
all of that into a suspect.
But I think we begin with the
certain assumption of identity
at some point in the online
world and then work our way back
to realizing that there's
nobody behind this.
So it would be interesting
to trace our relationships
between authenticating on one
hand and unanimity on the other
in our relationship, where
we're at, at this moment,
I think it's really
interesting one.
>> Just a small comment on that.
In the early days, it
was favoring of unanimity
and now favoring
of authentication.
>> Jason Farman:
Absolutely, yeah.
>> So [inaudible] number one,
the social identity
[inaudible] social identity
and to hold you accountable
what you did.
>> Jason Farman: That's right.
>> And the two should go back
and forth, whereas before,
the idea was freedom
and now I discovered
that that was not a good idea.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> So some places, I now go to.
I'll mention one, Future
Learn [assumed spelling].
It's a place I enjoy
its courses and so on.
They prefer you to authenticate
yourself and I always do
because they want
to know who you are.
>> Jason Farman: That's right.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> And it makes it more
of a social experience
and actually a social community.
>> Jason Farman:
Yeah, absolutely.
So if you look at the
early days of the internet,
especially around 1997, NCI came
out with a series of commercials
that essentially said, you
know, race doesn't matter,
gender doesn't matter,
disability doesn't matter,
we are mind to mind.
Is this utopia?
No, it's the internet.
So it's the idea that you could
remove your body completely
and come up with an entirely
new identity independent
of who your-- what
your body was.
And I think that mythology
played out and we saw
that the negative concept
that who's allowed to give
up their bodies and who among us
actually wants that, you know?
Yeah. I mean, you know, we
are primed by our bodies.
Do we actually want to
get rid of these bodies?
We don't. And so we want
our bodies to be a part
of our message exchanges because
there's notion of intimacy
across message exchange
and that's, I think,
covered in that whole book
that message exchange is a part
of intimacies, how we maintain
intimacy across distances,
and our bodies are part of that.
We want our bodies
connected in these exchanges.
So that's when I think we wanted
authentication to be a key part
of our social networks.
And you saw that, you know,
with the rise of Friendster
and Myspace in 2002-2003,
identities were a part of it,
you weren't working
on those platforms.
You didn't want to
be because you wanted
to connect with people.
And that defined social media
platforms from then on out
where you wanted who
you were as a person
to be present in
those exchanges.
>> And I think-- I know people
who get paid to write
on internet.
And when you become a paid
blogger or a paid columnist,
you want to be authenticated,
you want to be accountable,
and you have a kind of energy.
So whatever kind
of place you go to,
it's very important for that.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah, exactly.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: Could
you say a little more
about the use the seals
that everyone has in Japan--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: -- and why
at that comfortable moment?
And I had a certain image
where I saw the picture.
And then it made me think when
we write a wrong [inaudible],
we got like 17, quite anybody--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: -- who
gets a signal all of a sudden.
It seemed more-- you just--
I mean, I found that really
interesting, why the--
you know, at this
moment do you think?
>> Jason Farman: That people
have to carry seals on them?
>> Eleanor Shevlin:
Yeah, the seals
and the moves to
that, you know--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> Eleanor Shevlin:
-- [inaudible].
I mean--
>> Jason Farman:
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. Absolutely.
So I think, you know,
it is fascinating
to trace even our use of
signatures in PDF documents and,
you know, click here to
sign in, it looks nothing
like your signature but you
were the one who made the click.
And so the click is
an action, you know,
it's a performative act
that authorizes, right?
Yes but, you know, talking to
why people carry their seals,
there is-- Japan is
really fascinating in terms
of its technological
advancements, how we imagine
to be one of the most
technologically advanced
countries in the world.
You know, they had mobile
phones and mobile internet
and 3G long before we did.
So then our mobile explosion,
you know, was predated
by Japanese culture
by many years.
But then on the other hand,
you have this other desire
for physicality, for
materiality, and the honor
of having material and ways
that you cannot sign
things digitally.
You got to go in person.
Nobody can take your seal on
your behalf and sign anything.
You have to go and stamp.
So there is-- Yeah, I think--
And I think we as
a culture as well
in the United States are
circling back to that as well
to understand that the digital
and the material are not these
distinct spaces that materiality
and material culture are
very much embedded in,
in a digital society.
And yeah, it's interesting
in those kinds of ways.
>> But I think that what you
just said too about being a kind
of the very close
intricate relationship--
integral relationship between
digital material is one thing
that I-- and there
are so many things.
But one thing that
I greatly enjoy
about your talk [inaudible]
with the historical because--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
>> -- you know, I think
it's just refreshing to kind
of see that trio in here--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> -- and to take things
back and not conflate them.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah, right.
>> Do you know-- I mean because
that sometimes how things
are done.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah, yeah.
For this kind of--
>> Eleanor Shevlin: --
involve these other.
>> Jason Farman: Yeah, for work.
So this work is kind of
situated in the field
that could become
media archeology.
>> Right.
>> Jason Farman: So, you
know, making connections
and imagining genealogies
of media, you know, that--
so which does counter this
disruptive notion of technology,
you know, tech-- you know,
the digital media come in
and disrupt culture and
nothing is ever the same.
Rather, it's a tracing of
lineages and ideas across eras,
trying to find ancestors
among media that set the stage
for our contemporary moment
and trying to understand it
within a part of historical
context rather than thinking
that this moment
is a disruption.
Instead, it's very much a
long, long lineage of media
that have come before,
and cultural attitudes
that have come before that,
yes, must be understood
within their specific--
>> Within--
>> Jason Farman: -- within a
moment that they're not the same
and their historical
moments are not the same
but we can still learn
something by layering them
on top of one another.
>> Well, this isn't
really great.
But I was curious but I was
wondering if that's true
about the seals in Japan.
I mean, it's more like
a performance of power
of the state, you
know, when you said--
>> Jason Farman: Oh, yeah, yeah.
>> -- history, it does.
I mean, but I'm just actually
making an observation,
is applying for visas
and passports--
>> Jason Farman: Yes, yeah.
>> -- you have to like get the
stamps of the guy over there,
you can invite the person
in the window, et cetera.
So I mean I think
there are some--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah.
That's very--
>> -- we've got nothing there
and I'm sure it's also happening
in digital and analog
as well but I feel
like there's something--
>> Jason Farman: It's very--
>> -- that sort of-- This
is what the state is,
this is how it works.
This is how you, you
know, recognize that.
>> Jason Farman:
I think that's a--
>> Eleanor Shevlin: I know.
That's-- But don't you think
too they're coming backward
with the digital and kind of a
state than this idea of desire
of the individual
comes back to itself?
It's kind of maybe the way
it's envisioned can almost be a
rhetoric, you know, kind of--
>> Jason Farman:
Yeah, that's true.
So if you look at the different
seals that people carry
with them, they are
personalized.
>> Yeah.
>> Jason Farman: So you've
got your name, you know,
on the actual seals,
albeit it can be, you know,
the handles are personalized.
Depending on how much
money you've got, you know,
it can be very cheap materials
but some are very elaborate
and very personalized for that.
But I think you're right that it
is bound up in this bureaucracy
that values that
particular relationship
to the physical rather
than to something else.
And again, that may be
reproducible in different kinds
of ways that aren't
accepted by the bureaucracy.
But I think it exists within
the context of the digital
and also the context of
value in certain kinds
of material culture as well.
>> Just when you
go to the airport,
they'll photograph
you five times
and count [inaudible] five
different times you're
photographed and you're
kind of [inaudible].
They don't trust
one picture, they--
>> Jason Farman: Yeah, exactly.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah.
>> Sabrina Baron: Well, thank
you, everybody for coming--
>> Jason Farman: Yes, thank you.
>> Sabrina Baron: --
[inaudible] my volume
and you'll get a
lot of attention.
Our streaming stuff has been
getting a lot of attention,
so that will be really great.
Anybody who wants to
hold on for drinks
and dinner, please join us.
For listening to
Jason-- [Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.